Oh, Voidling. Oh, you came and you've watched me after I did the live stream.
Even though sometimes it's not fun when I'm lying. But I know I stream at really bad times.
But I still love you, Voidling.
You've got your own melody today. Oh, it is that melody.
I can't hear the background of the game. But I hope it sounds...
Oh, my mic. Hold on.
Yeldon. Yeldon. Yeldon. Right, okay. My microphone's back at the mouth.
Unfortunately, my voice is still broken. But hey, Vo.
That's what you get if you don't raise your voice. Oh, what do you mean?
I'm supposed to be raising my voice in between streams. What are you fucking...
What are you... What will you... What will you be talking about, you one?
Good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon.
I'm totally not opening up a box of shapes right now because I got a delivery.
I got me food.
A silent stream would go crazy.
Unfortunately, my voice is still broken. Now, obviously, let's talk about the elephant in the room.
Please, ladies and gentlemen, give me a little bit of credit.
Do you think I didn't plan for this kind of thing? I assure you everything's gonna be okay at the end of the day.
Please do relax and enjoy that your little sister's having a wee bit of time off, okay? Relax.
It's okay.
I assure you, even though I am very low IQ, I have planned for these things.
I know the results of these things. Everything's okay.
No, Veeler are not gonna be opening up their own fucking live stream platform that you can do what you want.
No, that's... No, no. Okay.
But don't worry. Give... Give it 48 hours, okay?
And then wherever the result is, is the result.
Okay, so don't worry. Mummy knows what to do. Mother knows best.
One of you has probably understood that reference because that's a Rapunzel.
Rapunzel, uh, Rapun... Mummy.
Oh my God, call me Nicocado, avocado. I am always two steps ahead.
Oh, that's terrible. Anyway, I apologize for how broken my voice is.
Obviously, under unique circumstances, I will actually be on time for once today.
I've got two hours of this game. I don't know how long it takes.
I was just gonna muck about in yapties in the background as always.
And then we are watching Austin Powers as a membership stream and then I'm...
I'm jumping offline to deal with the background stuff.
But if you... You know, it's already... It's gone through the appeal process.
I've messaged a few old friends that have contacts at YouTube. Hopefully one of them can pull through.
Please don't worry, okay? It's just a new account. That's it.
That's literally it. Have you not seen what happened?
You can open up a new account.
It's not perma-ban. People seem to assume it's perma-ban if it's for factual policies.
It's not perma-ban.
I'll let you know on one thing though. It was like...
You have up until 2029 to appeal it.
So the data is collected for five years before they finally purge it from the servers.
So, yeah, you can still argue for the account for a very long time.
So please don't worry, Pinpals, that you're gonna be okay. You'll be fine.
Obviously I did speak to Emma when I woke up a wee bit. She's okay.
She's just a bit shocked and I said, don't worry. I didn't expect it either.
She didn't get a third strike.
That's the fact of the matter. Check the emails. There was no third strike issue.
So we get to argue about that. So let's see what the result is.
But again, please don't worry. Everything's gonna be okay. It's me.
I know, I know, but strongy, you're so low IQ, you can hardly string a sentence together.
Now, yes, that is the truth. How dare you one? How dare you say that so confidently out loud?
Two, come on. I planned a lude agency.
Of course, I thought a little bit of a head of what might happen if someone was a bit too low.
Okay? So please don't worry. Pinpals, you're gonna be just fine. Okay?
You'll be just fine.
My fellow mergers.
No third strike. No. There was not a third strike issue for the channel to be closed.
Okay, I'm a monk for a quick club.
I love cooking, creamy soup.
Look at that. Don't worry.
I'm obviously a communicator.
I'm pulling all the strings I can.
Because obviously it would suck if you had to start fresh, but...
I feel a little better after you saying that. Yes, please don't worry.
Honestly, I know I'm low IQ. I know I'm daft. I know I'm not very smart.
But I have a wee bit of faith in me. Just a wee bit, all right?
No more eating.
I can't see the awesome power stream. It is gonna be... I'll put it up. I'll put it up.
Actually, I could message management to put it up for me.
Okay.
I have a bit more exciting news. We've gotten invited to a convention.
I forgot about this part. Right.
We're playing a game called Chain Together, but there's no togetherness. It's just me.
But that's because I'm a lazy sod.
I played this in a collab, but I actually found it rather satisfying.
Yes, a convention. Obviously, before we announce anything, we will get it confirmed.
Mummy, you can't... Wait, you guys go to conventions?
It's gonna be via the internet. Via the internet. Not physical. Not physical.
We're not molesting you just yet. Hold on.
Sadness is leaving. Thank you. Now only rage remains. Yes.
There's obviously...
Not in real life, Frank.
Oh, yeah. No, no. Sorry. I forgot that...
I forgot that you people go outside.
No, it's like an internet one where they're gonna...
I don't know what it comes from. It's the first time I've ever done anything like that.
And I've not got a Scooby-Doo what any of this is or how it works or that.
I've been invited. I just need to extend my hand and see what the fuck happens after.
Because I don't know how to get the girls to scoot about on those robot things.
Those are hilarious, but they cost too much money.
I think you have to rent it, which honestly makes perfect sense.
So it might be one of those things where we're all chilling at a booth talking to you.
People go outside. We go outside. That's what I'm asking you.
I didn't realize you thought it was an in real life convention. Where would you show up?
No. If the girls and I meet up, the likelihood is they're coming to me.
And we'll do an off-collapse for one week straight, just constant.
Would the con be in real life? No, it would be online. It would be via the internet.
If the girls and I meet up, 99% sure they're all coming to Australia.
They're all coming to see me down under.
And I'll show them the Aussie way. I'll teach them the HSPs and all that.
Hold on, I'm trying to drink my tea. Can you hear my little nails on it?
Veiler Mansion confirmed? I mean Mansion for a week, if they won.
Oh no, if the girls, like, if we genuinely did that off-collab, you wouldn't know the best part about it.
It can be expensed! It can be expensed!
I can get fucking taxed back on the price of their plane tickets and shit.
Shadow Wizard Money Gang. We love being registered as a business.
Do you want to know what other things you can do as a business?
You can go to Japan and call it cultural experience for your work.
And guess what? Oh, I didn't expect that.
That can be right off as well! Let's go! We love anime girls up in this bitch!
But yes, there's another off-collab. I'm afraid they'll be having to come to me.
But I would get PCs and stuff so the girls can have their own PCs signed in and stuff and do off-collabs.
And obviously I'm going to force them to lick my microphone!
Whoa, that sounds like a euphemism. But it's not. It's not a real euphemism at all.
It's actually what I mean.
Yeah, tax write off hotel. Oh, geez, I gave my fright.
Hold on, wait. I have the teleport thing on. How do I put it on?
Escape. Near safe location. If your character is stuck, highest point unlocked. Yeah, do that.
Okay, good. This is just a yap and all that.
If one of my friends is like a TikTok, does that work as a write-off?
One of my friends is like, yes, so if you're a TikTok creator, an influencer, whatever you want to call it,
what content they might use. So for example, if you're a nicocaddo, avocado,
you can write off the tax you get on food because you can show that you make content with that food.
As long as you can claim it. Now, I obviously don't claim... Oh, that's silly of me.
I obviously don't claim absolutely everything because I order quite a lot of outrageous things
such as an ice mold that is currently in the freezer right now waiting for the day to be used.
Whoa, why am I struggling? Bruh, I'm on my own. Why am I struggling so much with this one?
Trips, well, if you can prove that you're made up, made content, made you income, made you this, made you that,
was fruitful, then yes, you can. But don't take... Wait, hold on a minute, hold on, allegedly.
Hold on a minute. Do not take advice from a fucking cuttlefish on the internet about how to claim your taxes.
This is how it works for me. I have accountants and I've been in two countries now with a registered business
and, you know, the accountants in both countries were like, this is how it works.
Do not take advice from a cuttlefish. How do I keep doing the same thing over and over?
And expecting a different result. Over the internet for your thing, it sounds quite taxing.
Thank you, thank you. No, seriously.
Oh, for goodness... I'm having a stroke, sorry, I'm trying to talk to you.
This is why this is a YAPStream, okay? This is why it's a YAPStream.
But yes, hopefully, Pin Pills, you feel a bit rest assured.
As dumb as I am, I know, I know, please do understand that.
I have known about this as a very high possibility and please, no panic.
There's nothing to panic about.
As I said, factual policies do not get you perma-ban on YouTube.
Things like hate speech and all that get perma-ban.
As far as I'm aware, Emmy hasn't addressed how much she hates a certain video game franchises.
It's like a love-hate relationship, really.
Tax evasion? No!
It's like tax evasion is illegal, but tax avoidance is illegal, but tax evasion is fine or something like that?
Something really silly.
My ping is 200, I can't believe it.
Oh, I have that short to upload.
Reeflings, you guys are gonna be feasting very, very well.
So after the Austin Power, I'm basically pre-recordin' like five, six shorts, maybe even eight,
that are like, hopefully, high quality, wink, wink, me and high quality, name of worst duo.
No, you're ping!
Oh, that was a joke from, I did a collab and I thought that was my ping.
And it was not my ping, it was the high, how high we pinged.
All of us had 300 ping and the MISMA was like, erm, no.
This is a really satisfying gameplay in solo.
Like, it actually is, I don't care what anyone says.
Sorry, I'm making an e-girl version of this right now.
I need Catarina to fund it though.
Her mafia monies to fund it, cause this is a...
It's like really satisfying, like getting to the next bit and then it's like, oh no, I lost progress.
Oh wait, no I didn't.
It's like really, if you don't end up having to like, climb on the barrel, it's really, erm, thingy.
How's your day been? It's just started!
My day started with you, obviously.
I woke up and I was like, hmm, something's not right, something's in the air, what's going on?
And then I saw Shivi actually, Shivi was the reason I found out about it.
Cause she was like, I'm so worried and I'm like, oh, why are you...
Oh, I did not mean to do that. I was like, oh, don't be worried.
It is much smoother than being tethered to three people, honestly.
Mummy's so independent, she doesn't need anime girls to finish.
This is really satisfying to play on your own.
I'm getting a little serotonin boost the higher I get, you know?
This woman is one of the three reasons why I'm still alive. Ask her to god.
You know what?
I hope things get better, fuck yeah.
And also, you should look forward to like, the next video games that come out.
Oh! Apparently that new short video game came out that's like, ballerin'.
Solo chain together equals only act, exactly.
Who's serotonin?
Oh, someone sent me a marshmallow. I'm so sorry to disappoint you, little reflin.
A reflin sent me a marshmallow and they were like, are we going to have a certain science member join?
And I think you're talking about uneology that I designed on that stream.
No, my nails are not after uneology.
But that girl's design has been ranked the second most favourite so far.
Are you going to play Concord? Aren't they not melted?
No, not Deadlock. A different one.
The one by, I don't know what's going on but this is a good accent.
Thanks, it's Scottish, I spawned in with it. It's really good.
Whoa, almost got spanked by that wire.
No, it was that other video game by that streamer.
Oh my god, mail streamer mentioned.
But it was made by a video game streamer.
Can you hold on, thank you.
Space Marines, Spectre. It must be Spectre, and it has like $90 skins.
And then a clip of him went viral because he was like, I don't think $4,000 is a lot for a mattress.
And everyone was like, what?
What do you mean $4,000 isn't a lot for a mattress?
That's like people's rent and then some. That's insane.
To spend on a mattress?
And then everyone was like, oh yeah, this guy went to private school and was like, oh, that's why he said that.
But he said like the skins were really expensive and stuff in the game.
But honestly, controversial take. The game actually didn't look that horrific to me.
Oh god, it's a dragon.
Hi.
Go grease landing, we're burning up the quarter mile.
Grease landing, go grease landing.
Dream boom boom, she can mean boom boom.
Grease landing.
God, MISMA did this.
I'm like 99% sure MISMA drove this.
Okay.
Whoa, this is fun.
It's like getting my driver's license without having to do the driver part.
Sorry, this is actually so satisfying.
This is such a good game.
Kailua, thank you for the 20.
Oh my god, thanks for your super chat, Terry.
It's mine now.
All non-tax advice is like super happy you've gotten this group together.
They're all so sweet and I'm really happy.
Talking to y'all.
All the lovable MISMA on it.
Oh, thank you.
I'm glad you like my girlies.
I love them to smithereens.
They're precious.
Oh, oh, I'm edging it.
I'm getting edged.
Okay, we made it.
Oh, I'm glad you like them.
And thank you, Kailua, for the 20s.
For your tip and your super chat.
Right, let me finish this tea.
This tea.
Okay, uh-uh.
I'm tired of drinking room temperature tea.
I said it.
And I'm going to try and take some photos for no particular reason after string.
Sorry, my voice just cracked if you heard that.
15 is the most I would ever spend on a skin.
But that's pushing out.
God, imagine if you ever collabed with a game and it had skins in it.
I'd buy it.
Oh, I'd love that.
I saw Vishojo collabed with that game.
You know the one that get mobile.
Smay.
And I was like that.
I was like, oh my God.
Fricking congratulations to them.
That's the coolest thing I've ever fricking seen.
Um, you know, not my game type.
I'd be fucking playing it about my skin.
I put it that way.
Damn, Brian.
Super happy you've gotten this group together.
Good morning, Brian.
Jeez.
I'm really happy talking to all of you.
All the love to Mama Stromi.
Ah.
Thank you, Niddle, for the tip.
Brian, do you want to read it out or will I read it out?
You don't seem awake this morning, Brian.
Some coffee.
Speaking of upcoming games, Silent Hill 2 Remake coming out next month.
Can't wait to see if Bloober team did a good job.
Is their team called Bloober?
I'm investing my stonks right now.
You want to play Shiba in college?
Um, look, as much as, you know, we've done rather well, I don't think we're that influential.
Although, did you see that tweet from Princess and Despire?
That new game that came out.
They were like, oh, if you can't afford your game, just pirate it.
It's no skin off of our nose.
And I'm like, damn, I want to be a game studio like you, the fuck?
They were like, yeah, if you don't have the money, you can buy it later when you do type thing.
I was like, fuck it.
Hell based on rent.
Right.
Okay, then one, two, three, jump.
One, two, three.
One.
Oh, that scared me.
I did not see that.
I.
I didn't even- I never even saw those!
I fucking went right for it!
RID.
Okay.
Wait!
They updated- this wasn't in the multiplayer!
Is it because I'm playing solo and I'm being punished?
Oh my god, they're punishing me for being mildly good at the game.
How dare they?
I'm being punished for winning!
I don't remember that in the colour.
RID.
Oh my god, wait!
They're so smart!
They've adapted the map for solo players.
Brian!
Okay, Brian clearly needs a bit of coffee.
You're taking a moment now, Brian.
Do you need to go back to sleep?
Is it too early for you?
By the way, before you're like, who the fuck is Brian?
Brian is the name of the TTS.
Okay.
Oh, that's a trampoline.
Oh, right.
Okay, let's go.
Deep beat.
Time and time again, it's been proven that piracy is good for-
There is another game dev studio that did that.
I can't even remember its name though.
They were just like, ah, you win, basically.
But it wasn't in a mean way.
It was just like, in a- oh my god, please, don't.
Stop!
This is like the most inefficient way to do it, the anime!
No, no, no, no!
Big jump!
Hey, Brian has over 9000 thing right now.
That voice comes from everywhere in nowhere.
Yeah, so Brian's the name of the text to speech.
And he is the one who commentates everything.
All the dough knows on stream for me.
And that's why I say Brian.
So if your name happens to be Brian, you might be rather fond of my streams,
because I tell him off.
I go, Brian, when he interrupts me.
So yeah, if your name is Brian, congrats.
You have won the lottery of chance that I might say your name at random.
I am going to do a Pokemon stream in the future.
And on Marshmallow, you can put your name if you want.
I've got to put this wrong this bit.
Oh wait, no, it's like up to the ground.
Going to talk into the dev team to get your own custom voice right now.
Yeah, I was going to do a Pokemon stream, but you have to put your name in Marshmallow,
but you're not allowed to sign it.
I don't want anyone, if you sign it automatically in the bin, I'm not pulling from that name.
I'm going to put all your names in a randomizer for the Pokemon stream,
and I'll show it on stream, like randomize it, and we'll take it from there.
By the way, Stronio, Vishojo collabed with Nike 2 a few months ago.
Quite a few of the girls covers.
Oh my god, that's fantastic!
Freakin' Iron Mouse has been absolutely killing it.
She came out with that song, it was like Pop Candy.
I don't know if you've seen the music video, I watched it like a lot.
And it was like that Pop Candy.
Oh for fuck's sake, I can't remember any of it.
It was like so good.
I was going to say, oh, did you like Amy's cover of Fortnite Metal Pass?
Can you understand why it was stuck in my head for so long now?
It was so good.
It will return very shortly.
A Devil Anarchy?
It was like the one where she was in a...
I think I'm above.
And I'm booted up my PC!
Yes, honestly, I'm going to get a lot of behind the scenes work.
I want to do Mimi's song covers as well.
I'm just going to test it, and if they don't go anywhere, then I'll just focus on other stuff.
So when you say my name without signing, do you mean like my first real name?
Yes, so when we play Pokemon, I can obviously name the Pokemon after you.
And I will...
Well, I was actually going to get...
No, I mean, I see to sing that, why is this dealer taking the piss?
Because I love Amy's voice.
And I thought it'd be really funny if she covered it.
Like in her reaction, why is this dealer?
Yeah.
Oh, Brian, you're late!
I already know.
Brian, stop it.
Thank you, Nero, for the tip.
Brian, as in he came, what's going on with you, son?
Yeah, so you put your real names, and then I'll name the Pokemon at random after you.
But I'll have a randomizer so that...
I don't know how that went so well.
So then there's a chance I can be like, Adam, go to battle!
Or whatever your name might be.
But yes, not your online handle, your actual real name.
That's why there's no one allowed to sign on it.
Because if you go like, ha, my name is...
My name is...
And this is my username.
Disqualified.
But don't worry, I'll tweet about it or I'll say about it.
Like way before the Pokemon stream.
The Pokemon streams aren't until October if I'm not mistaken.
Unless someone's got my schedule right now that I leaked.
I don't think Pokemon...
The Pokemon's in October.
I was gonna play Pokemon Ruby...
Pokemon Black...
Or way, I don't know what one you want me...
Only first name, don't put your...
Yeah, please don't give me your full legal name, your social security number,
and the four digits on the back of your card.
I do not need that to name a Pokemon.
As much as it would be nice to come and teleport to you.
No, I do not need that to name Pokemon that I catch.
No, not you joking about it as soon as I typed it.
Black or white stream base?
Yeah, I played Pokemon Ruby, Pokemon Black or White.
And I played the...
Is Pokemon Black or White Gen 5?
I did Gen 4, 3 and 5.
Those were my Pokemon games.
I tried to get into Pokemon Aloha.
That just...
No, that was not happening.
I think we'll play the...
How do you call it?
What is this one, isn't it?
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, Mr. Krabs.
Oh gosh, I forgot.
Was it this one?
What is this below?
Oh, that caught my memory so good.
Yeah, Sun and Moon was hard.
Yeah, I couldn't finish it.
You didn't like Gen 7.
So I played Aloha.
And then...
I couldn't...
I just kept...
I did the first battle and it was like...
You know, the gyms are different in Aloha.
It was like, you get an onslaught and I'm like,
oh, that's fine, like I can do the onslaught.
The dialogue just kept going and going
and going and going and going.
I'm like, shut the fuck up.
I just want to play the game.
I just want to play the fucking game.
It would not shut up.
It was like still holding my hand,
like solid two hours into it.
I'm like, bro, at least we put Gen 3 in that.
The game like wraps it up.
It's like, now you're on your own,
you're going to like go defeat your dad in a gym type thing.
Where the heck am I?
Where am I?
Oh, you mean it wasn't difficult.
It just would not stop talking.
Oh, wow.
I put it like here?
What?
No.
Okay.
Highest checkpoint.
Yeah.
Starting with X and Y,
they really started to dumb down the game.
No!
Wait, what?
I lost that progress.
I lost that progress because I came here.
Oh my God, this game is so stinky.
This game is so stinky.
Yeah.
I beat Sun and Moon,
and even after beating the Elite Four,
there was still dialogue.
Oh, like literally it was like...
Oh, I'm drowning.
Sorry, sorry.
I'm drowning because I'm complaining about Pokemon.
They're forcing you to take another bath.
My pheromones.
Oh, my feet are on screen as well.
What is this thing there?
Wait, what?
Is this a secret?
No, no.
Do not go down there.
That does not look like a secret to me.
Right, let's try this again.
Do you think Mummy would like Papers, Please?
I have fantastic news for you, Reflynn.
Absolutely gorgeous news for you.
I've played 30 minutes of Papers, Please,
but I never completed it because I sucked at it
and I raged quite off of it.
So we're going to play it this time again,
and we'll play it with you,
and you can get me to the end of the game
because I suck at those like...
I've seen...
Is it supposed to be like Hello...
No, not Hello Neighbor.
It's like Spy...
Your neighbor's not your neighbor game or something.
Papers, Please is kind of like that.
We're getting all the endings.
I've not even ended...
I've not finished it one.
You've got too much faith.
If you like Papers, Please, you might not at the broadcast.
I've been looking into
how much money I've spent on video games
since I started streaming,
and, ooh, Reflynn.
I think I'm going to have to start playing
a few more Xbox Game Pass games
because, ooh, oh dear, oh dear, Reflynn.
Oh, that was me.
I think since debut,
I've spent like $800 on video games.
Australian dollars, that is.
Australian dollars, but...
Yeah, I did not realize how much I had been willing...
Now, don't get me wrong.
I earned that money back and all that type thing,
and I get a little cheeky, tiny tax back on it.
But $800 since debut,
I'm like, I'm going to have to start farming them
Xbox games with them free-to-play games
because, ooh, I've been a bit willy-nilly.
A wee bit willy-nilly with my spending, Reflynn.
Hmm.
You accept gifted games on your throat?
I did not accept any of them.
I felt really bad.
I feel... I don't know...
Right, so this is just me and my way of thinking.
And my way of thinking is very wrong, okay?
Probably, I don't know.
I'm not very smart.
My...
Like, I don't think you should pay for content
in terms of, like, literally funding my games.
It's not that it's icky or anything like that.
It's just for me, personally.
Like, if other streamers do it, fucking knock yourself out.
Like, it's got nothing to do with me.
That's not my business.
I couldn't get less of a resource.
But just, I feel a bit weird about the concept of you
buying a game for me to stream and, like, do my thing with.
Alright, I've not been here before.
Hmm.
But I understand the reason why I was getting gifted
on my StreamSnipe account was to play games with you.
I understand that, but, yeah.
All willy nilly?
Yep.
All lax today's a call.
All willy nilly.
So more Overwatch to save money.
Got it.
No, no, no, no.
After this week's membership Overwatch playing,
that's it for Overwatch for quite a hot second.
Where the fuck are they going now?
Up.
Yeah, it looks like up.
How complicated is tax?
Not very.
I just go to the accountant.
And I'm like, hey, I want to claim these.
And then, and then that's it.
I get to pay extra tax because I'm a foreigner, though.
Yay!
I get to pay extra taxes and not receive the benefits
of being a citizen.
Yippee!
That's basically what it's like.
How nice.
I know!
So kind.
Thank you, Australian government.
Oh, Australia.
The land of the prisoners.
I actually don't know the national anthem here.
Me wondering why my visa's in limbo.
And that I might be getting kicked out of the country
at any second.
Yippee!
Let's go, government.
Yay!
That's right.
Tax the fuck out of me.
Yeah!
I love you, tax.
Actually, you know what, I will say though,
I prefer to be taxed in Australia than in Scotland
because Australia has much nicer taxes
if you're a business.
Versus in the UK, the tax...
Oh, who goes there?
By the Pope.
Mummy, your collapse confused me.
What, do you so say when I clap with my hands
is the other thing?
No, that's bad.
Riflin, that's naughty.
That's naughty.
If you are a snowberry,
I have a fun little update for you
if you're lurking in the shadows.
Your gorgeous little...
I can't say that.
I was about to say something to us.
Your gorgeous beloved polar bear
is gonna have a highlight video
coming out soon of Super Subducer.
So that's one highlight on Mercy,
one on AC,
and then next on the agenda
is Sheebie's getting a highlight reel.
And there's gonna be more shorts coming soon to you.
So soon to you.
Oh, I forgot about the angel wings.
I've not been collecting them.
I probably could have done it
if I was smart enough, but...
Where am I to go over there?
Um...
Yes, it is a fun little highlight video
of one of our Subducer gameplays,
and she goes,
I love True Gentleman.
Sorry, I know it's your meme,
and I shouldn't impede on your...
Where am I?
Over there.
I shouldn't impede on your memes, snowberries,
but I'm so sorry.
I fucking love True Gentleman.
I'm gonna get it as a sand board.
I don't care.
I'm getting it as a sand board, okay?
I love it.
True Gentleman.
But what will you do with them?
Not like you can reattach them.
Oh, wait, what did I say?
Did you see the highlight with Azura and Mercy?
It was so cute.
Oh, no, I'm not seeing it yet.
That's what I'm saying.
Like, if you want to ask me,
like, oh, how do you like being a streamer,
a VTuber, however,
I absolutely adore it,
but it's like, what's the downside?
It's like, I literally cannot keep up
with my gen mates,
and it pains me so much.
Angel, I would get the Angel Wing,
but it's literally,
I've not been collecting the other ones,
so Ripperoni, Pepperoni,
there's no point.
And I'm pretty sure the Angel Wing
is to like get things, is it not?
Oh, spicy.
Oh my God, I'm hardly even near the end.
Jeez.
I honestly thought the developer,
right, not in a rude way.
If I let me see my sense,
not in a rude way,
I thought this game was a bit more
of a cash grab than I originally thought.
But no, the dev gen-
Oh, who goes there?
The developer genuinely put
like a lot into this.
I don't know if it was a solo developer
or a small team,
but no,
my impressions of this game were wrong,
and I admit it, I'm wrong.
I apologize to the dev team.
I thought this was a bit more of a cash grab
than I originally thought.
Jeez, why am I struggling with that?
True gentleman, I've ruined that friendship
living your head.
Oh no, I don't know,
but I've ruined your friendship.
Was that in the highlight?
After one year streaming every day,
will you start to take breaks?
I don't have an answer yet for you,
my dear refling.
The reason is,
I don't know what the future holds,
so if I can get away with it,
and things still continue as they do,
I mean, as far as I'm aware,
the girls aren't disgruntled about,
you know, me taking a few days
to do stuff when they ask for it.
They ask for breaks,
I have like scripts in that,
they've been kind of waiting
on like a few scripts and whatnot.
What does that button mean?
Oh, like as far as I'm aware,
everyone's alright.
If they want advice, they are,
oh wait, what?
Did the game just rebate me?
No.
So when Gen 2 come along,
obviously I'll have them for two months
under my,
the pre-DBU stage,
and depending on what girls we get,
if we get girls that are either hidden gems
or maybe more established,
I don't know what the dealio is going to be
under your angel wing, yes.
But like for example,
say if we got people that were like
ex-agency members,
they've done this rodeo before,
they want a fresh start
and they want to join Veealer.
Well, most likely all things point
to that girl's not going to need anything from me,
other than maybe an ASMR script if she wants it.
Like she doesn't need me to analyse her content,
she doesn't need me to say like,
oh, you should,
you know, this stream is most likely going to get you popular
or da-da-da-da.
She's been there, done that.
She doesn't need me, you know what I mean?
Whereas if we get like people that,
I believe are hidden gems,
but that might need a bit more polishing,
that kind of terminology,
then, yeah.
I don't know what the answer is.
I would very much like to continue
to stream every day.
Whether or not that would mean
I might peel back on,
say for example,
like the fucking mega long streams
are kind of what killed me the most.
Feet pics equal followers trust.
Where did that come from?
Is that me giving advice to Jen too?
Oh, but just post your feet, by the way.
It's real.
Wait, am I to cross the train?
I'm to cross the trains?
Oh, I'm not sure that one.
I mean, we did end up posting our wee feet.
Oh, what on earth?
I'm literally playing frog with the train station.
Oh, come on.
Right, hold on.
Let us observe the train schedule.
One, two, three, and then four.
Oh, so it's literally just a line.
Okay, well, when you put it like that,
that was so simple.
Post feet, insta subs, honestly, though.
Honestly, honestly.
But yeah, if we get independent creators,
I honestly don't really see why I would need to ease up.
If anything, I could probably go a bit more balls to the wall
with my project.
I'm gonna go on top.
I don't trust going inside the carriage.
Hook and followers are feet.
Keep them loyal with poctin.
Keep them ready to plait me for gen three.
Right, we're going in an elevator.
Peeler is the way to cross, real.
Me messaging Azura like,
hey, when you got that audio for me, baby girl.
Honey, yeah.
Keep my pee hair, you know what I'm saying?
But yes, today I am going offline bang.
I'm not gonna yap.
I'm not gonna overstay my welcome.
I'm gonna redirect into sheepsters, all that jazz.
Obviously, with the recent, I've got things to do,
but I also have things to do for you, Reefling,
so you guys have content because we're now entered
the fourth month of streaming.
To put it nicely, I'm not mad at myself.
I'm just disappointed for the lack of content
that I have given you.
I am a bit about it.
Feet pics when duck cream brulee, Reefling sir.
Thank you for your cherry.
I have fantastic news for you.
If you go on my channel and you click on oldest live streams
and you see monetization celebration,
click that live stream for no particular reason.
You're gonna have a fucking field day with that stream, sir.
Thank you.
I already got you covered, okay?
I already got you covered.
Lack of content.
Your daily streams and several member streams for a week.
Stop slacking with a lack of content.
I just, what I'm annoyed about is I want to be
much further with milestones.
I already want to be at the stage where I am...
I've already up to date with my milestones.
I am now fully writing milestone content
that you, Reeflings, want to see.
God, we're in the city now.
Oh my gosh, there's supermarket simulator down there.
Right, that's the Reboot-Op supermarket simulator.
I really find those games satisfying.
I don't know why, but...
Well, this is a rather satisfying game, so...
Lack of content, you put it somewhere.
I just like the collabs as well.
Poor Poseidon.
Yumi's been waiting on the collab as well.
Literally, I can do Yumi's one right now.
Poseidon, I need a very specific sound effect.
And I don't want to stress out my gen mate,
but only she can do it because my fucking thing failed.
I don't have a wooden bowl.
And...
I feel really bad about making everyone wait for the collabs.
And I need to arrange...
Why am I fucking this up so much?
And I need to arrange more as well.
Stroney Yarns for the Weegee Life.
I mean, I'm going back into education.
Unironically, I'm going to beauty school.
So I can learn to do ASMR and facials and stuff.
Because I'd really like it.
Brian!
And why are the notifications so delayed today?
Stream element's feeling alright.
She's going up the ventilation shaft.
I hold on to the crane.
I see her.
Aloha.
I'm letting you cook.
Thank you.
Yumi, I can do your collab ASAP once...
I get...
a moment to think.
Give me a moment to...
Can you hold on?
Thank you.
You're going to give me some sweet lack of content.
Really lack of content.
I can consume in my spare time, honestly.
I just like being there.
I like the...
Sorry.
I don't know what that noise was either.
It sounded like I had a kazoo on the end of my throat.
Lower accurate facials.
This is crazy.
I'm really passionate about ASMR.
I want to do beauty school for it.
I've been looking around
if there's like a six week course near me.
But unfortunately there's not.
So I can't do it until I pop off.
I really am passionate about ASMR.
As much as folk want to...
As much as folk want to be like,
Oh, ASMR's a cash grab.
This is that.
What? No!
You didn't save my last location?
This is so far back.
It's like an ocean noise.
Really passionate about facials, huh?
I need a throat show.
Because of how rubbish my voice is right now.
It's so broken.
So, so broken right now.
But yeah, I want to get more collabs out of the way.
I'm entering my fourth month
and my little goal of a hundred VTuber collabs
is not happening if I don't light a fire under my ass.
But I've made contact with them
another agency to...
No!
Don't make me do it again.
I'm going to be angry.
No, I'm angry.
I'm angry.
No.
People think ASMR's a cash grab.
I think people see ASMR's like low quality content
because it's like...
It's like...
And it's like, no, that's your fucking perception.
Like, damn right, I'm going to sit in my ASMR booth
and tap on shit for 30 seconds and whisper...
30 seconds, 30 minutes and get distracted about LMNOP.
You will get there.
Don't rush yourself.
I want to already...
I don't know if you remember,
I did a community post ages ago
that was like tell me what trigger words you want me to say.
I haven't recorded that yet
but like after this stream,
I am completely ignoring all the girls
which I feel really bad about.
So what I call it is me being selfish.
That's how I describe it.
When I finish stream and do work for myself,
I call it me being selfish
which is terrible because it's not.
It's just me being doing content, you know?
But like today is all about me.
I'm putting together Shibi's proposal for her donathon.
I'm sending away her donathon trailer
and then it's all me.
Everything I do for the rest of the day is all me
and I call it being selfish.
When it's not, it's just fucking making content.
It's only selfish by not neglecting the reason.
But that's what...
It's not that it annoys me.
I suppose the better word would be like
I wish I could do more.
I wish I had more energy.
I wish I could do this.
I love Emmy shorts
and I've wrote scripts for four ASMR shorts
being like talking about the microphone quality,
talking about how much do they make,
like I was going to show my income,
I was going to show the...
What the fuck?
That seems rather dangerous, don't you think?
I'm not going to drive that.
Oh, I need to drive it to get past, okay.
Mummy has earned the right to be selfish.
Yeah, so it means tomorrow when I put up
a stream with Sheevee for the stream snapping.
Oh my God, it's a tight fit.
Oh yeah, right now.
Beep, beep.
X.
Oh my God, I'm so good at this job.
I'm such a multitasker.
Not only do I...
There's a little platform here.
Are you forklift certified?
Ladies love me, I'm forklift certified now.
You're familiar with tight fits, aren't you?
Right, right, right.
Hold on a minute, hold on a minute.
But yeah, I'm going to get a bath,
I'm going to shave,
I'm going to take my little foes with my collar,
or your collar, our collars together.
I've also have a picture of my hands
holding a ruler with my nails
to put on the alternative Twitter.
Like, I'm trying.
I know things take long.
Wow, that was actually really lucky.
Poopy time.
I think it's over.
Someone call Oshia, this stuff don't look safe.
No, I don't think it looks safe either.
I like the graffiti detail.
N.
I.
Wa...
Wait, is that Russian?
Weird.
I need to look into the developer.
There is a new developer game that I...
Oh god, it's a maze.
Purple or yellow?
Yellow on the outskirts of the maze?
And then this one?
Blue?
What?
Okay, get wrecked.
Sorry, but that was too obvious.
So was you too obvious.
Our collar.
Russia intensified.
Wait, when does it spin?
I don't know.
One, two, three, four, five.
Okay, it spins on five.
It spins on five.
She's gaming.
Oh, you never showed the cover, I guess.
Oh, I didn't show it.
No, I showed your collar on yesterday's hand cam stream.
I showed your dog bowl as well.
It looks so cute.
I'mma fill it up with kibble for you.
No, I wouldn't make you eat dog food.
I'm sorry.
That's not for me.
Some people are like really into it.
That's where I draw the line.
I'm like, hold on a minute.
Now, someone who ate cat food.
My fellow Americans.
Someone who ate cat food.
By accident, I was a child.
And by accident, I was an adult.
It was very recent.
I will not.
I'm not into like actually making me busy.
That stuff.
I put cereal in it.
Do you want frosted treadies?
It's the best.
I love frosted treadies.
I used to eat the absolute out of them.
And they were so, it didn't even matter if they were soggy.
They're just delicious.
They were so delicious.
That's it.
I'm important frost.
I'm importing frosted treadies right the fuck now.
Right the fuck now.
I'm doing a treadies cereal tier list.
There you are.
Mm-hmm.
Happy little accent.
You ate cat food thinking you'd become.
Right.
Like some other visevers.
I don't know.
I can't imagine myself not being a cutlerfish.
I can imagine myself like dressing up
to be another different kind of
VTuber.
But like as I said,
oh when it comes to me,
no, no, don't register that as my highest point.
Oh thank goodness.
The quality control in cat and dog food is terrible.
It is.
100%.
Like I was wanting to make homemade meals for my pooders.
But,
I don't even have time to make food for myself.
Big jump.
It's balls.
We're
here,
and then
and then we squeeze past.
Race Krispies.
Oh no.
I'm sorry,
your miracle abs cancelled.
I'm afraid that's not an acceptable answer.
Honey Cheerios.
Crunchy Nut as well.
Don't laugh.
That's the name of the cereal brand.
It's called Crunchy Nut.
What is this?
What?
Am I supposed to do a U-turn around this building?
Wait, no, sorry.
I must be missing the thing here.
Rep you meme.
Am I supposed to jump on the crane?
No.
No, there's something...
Crunchy Nut when the reflins are...
Oh!
Oh, fucking sick.
Okay.
It is.
It's called Crunchy Nut.
Don't laugh.
It's some really good cereal as well.
I really like honey.
I've always enjoyed honey severely.
It just is very nice.
The sweetness is...
What the fuck is that?
I failed the visual novel dating simulation
interaction was scrawny.
Real.
But yeah, I was wanting...
Oh, that's where I was getting at before I got distracted
as I always do because I can't strike a sentence together
for the life of me.
I...
I'm doing shorts about Ace Marne.
I was going to show income and different analytics and stuff.
But because I have so little freaking content,
it's really hard to pull off the shorts that I want to do
right at this very second.
And I want to start doing content
that you guys ask for.
And I want to record
an audio role-play version of the hypnosis streams
and just doing all of this.
But I keep getting distracted.
Obviously, I woke up today and I was like,
right, I'm going to get so much done.
And then Poo Wee Immerses account
gets a wee bit of a...
It gets put on a post-champ and I'm like,
okay, a little bit of a distraction.
But that's basically what happens.
Something new will pop up and I'm like,
oh, I didn't expect that I was going to have to do that.
What the fuck?
What?
Are we getting magnetized over there?
I think so.
So I'm just going to say pulling off shorts, exactly.
Great idea.
Veal or Dayton Simulator.
I did talk to the girls about that
because it can be easily done
and it's a hell of a lot cheaper than what the fuck I paid for.
But the video game's getting wrapped up
and it can finally be shipped.
Unfortunately, I am rather...
Disappoint...
Have I got metal in my head?
Wait, oh, I'm to hold on to the metal?
No, what?
Have I got metal in my head?
Please be real.
I'm really disappointed in myself
when it comes to the video game.
Obviously, round two will be a lot better,
but I'm not very pleased,
especially with the money I spent on it.
But hey, that is life.
Look, everything's...
You can learn from the past.
Don't dwell on it.
Don't get annoyed at yourself.
I'm getting the plat trophy in the game.
More like you're getting the plat trophy in the game.
Thank you.
Got another tenor shift.
Do you need a lock-in for the tenor shift?
I'm so sorry.
Please hydrate.
Hold on, she went over the buildings.
What's over the buildings?
Oh my gosh, it's Bioshock Infinite.
Bioshock Infinite.
Wait, what?
Is that really what I'm supposed to do?
You're here all night, huh?
Why are you so cool?
Am I really supposed to...
Hold on, let me lock in gamers.
Mommy's locking in.
Oh, I didn't realize it was pushing me forward.
Sorry, hold on, let me lock in.
Serious face on, serious face.
You know what?
Right, hold on a minute.
I'll let you...
You know what?
In...
Right, no, breathe.
Okay, hold on.
See, all you have to do is breathe through video games, honestly.
I don't know what the problem is.
All you gotta do is breathe through.
You should do a free keyboard giveaway.
I doubt that nobody would want to salate over the keys.
I'm actually, for one of my Donathon rewards,
I am doing an ASMR video of me cleaning my gamer keyboard.
It's gonna be fucking vile.
I also have a mouse mat that is gonna get washed
for in the video as well.
It's like three years of accumulation.
Maybe even more, actually.
Most likely more.
But I was gonna do...
Oh, it goes...
Oh, I got...
Oh, I'm getting pushed.
Oh, my God, don't push me.
It's gonna be a Donathon reward.
I can thankfully prepare a lot
for my Donathon fun stuff that I'm doing.
It is absolutely vile.
The amount of food, dust, dead skin, cat hair,
my hair, it's pretty...
Oh, no, wait.
I could have picked up the other one.
It counts, like, on over all your files.
I didn't know that.
I feel dumb now that I walked past it.
Under those keys has to be absolutely putrid, honestly.
Mingen putrid.
Disgustan! Disgustan!
Which one do you use?
I went for a shite and didney flush.
Well, it's fucking one of yours!
Disgustan!
Yeah, that's basically...
Fuck it!
Right, no.
Do the timer again.
I hate when video games do that.
Surprise timer, but cat hair.
Time to call and kill me.
Autistic girlfriend builds Legos Wind.
Do you actually want that?
Because I will happily make that.
You'll never guess what.
I have the perfect.
Let me write it down.
Yeah, that's another thing.
Like, I want to do all these fun ideas we came up together.
I hear music.
I heard that.
Whose music was that?
Was it this?
Oh, it's this.
Okay, hold on.
Analizing, analyzing, analyzing, analyzing, analyzing.
Analizing, analyzing, analyzing.
And we've analyzed.
Who wouldn't want such a glorious anal smirk?
What can I say?
I'm just a signal.
Except you're welcome.
Wait, you could go different ways?
Have I gone the wrong way?
No.
Something is bumping the tunes.
I better not be copyrighted.
How many do you have on that list?
I have so much.
Like, that's what I'm saying.
Like, when it's selfish.
So tomorrow I'm going to wake up at midnight to record
because I'm probably going to write ASMR scripts and stuff.
But I'm wanting to wrap up a lot of my collabs.
So once Yumi and Poseidon are done, I'm like 99% sure
that's all the collab lines I have.
So I'm going to go pester my collab partners that agreed
because I think, I think I have like,
Twi-whoa!
Oh my God, is this invisible?
That is...
Can my brain do this?
Right, okay, hold on, hold on.
My brain can't do that.
Selfish, more like selfish stuff.
I will.
Right, hold on.
Let me, you know, I...
North, west, north, west, north, east, south, east.
Hold on.
Whoa, tree.
Hee-hee.
Hee-hee, helping with the Michael Jackson.
Wait, what?
Oh no, I don't remember this part.
Is it before or after?
I must...
Poseidon is before you!
Oh, it's on!
Okay, right, hold on.
Oh, I forgot, that did that so well.
Right, it's before that last rock.
Okay, let's try that again.
Right, you know what?
I want your collab, Obama.
What?
I've already forgotten.
Right, open it up again, one more time.
Forward, left, right, okay.
Uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh.
Right, and then up, and then line up the tree.
And go a little to the right, and then go a little to the right,
and then go forward, and then go up,
and then before the tree, take a little left,
and then look forward.
Okay, I'm done.
Okay, let's go!
Oh boy, follow me.
The Obama, I'm afraid, sorry.
We follow idol culture, aren't we, Laura?
We do not interact with males, okay.
I don't even know my own dad.
He wasn't even there for my conception.
He wasn't even there for, yeah, no.
I don't even know what dad is.
Shame, shame truly.
Uh, right, what are you?
Whoa!
Oh, I get it.
Oh, this is cute.
I like whatever this is.
Whoa, it's like throwing me forward, please don't do that.
No scrawny dad.
Tragic, truly.
It is, it is tragic.
Okay, if I go too fast,
the, like, momentum makes me fall.
So let's...
Careful.
Dad, yeah, my dad went out to get some milk, sorry.
I'm sorry, you have to learn this way.
It's Johnny's dad watching the stream right now,
like, I spoke to him,
and he says I look a lot better recently,
and I'm like, yeah, things are resolving.
I got, like, a manager,
and I'm like, okay, I'm done,
I'm done, I'm done.
Yeah, things are resolving.
I got, like, a manager and stuff,
and I'm getting another one.
And he was like, oh, that's good, Johnny.
No, because he was, like,
every time I see you,
you look like shit,
and I'm like, thanks, dad.
But he'll see how it is,
but we spoke very briefly yesterday,
and he was like, oh, you look better,
and I'm like, I know.
Also, do you want to know
a fun fact about my magpie?
It does tricks!
Um, I am very close
to holding a magpie.
That's all I'm saying.
Oh, how did I manage that again?
Johnny's dad, if you're watching this,
and you're raised an excellent living being.
I did be breathing and stuff.
So, my magpie,
it's the male magpie.
Oh, my God, male.
He can catch cashews in the air,
so I throw them up in the air,
and he catches them.
He doesn't want me to put them on the ground.
He likes the fun of
swooping together.
So, magpies can play,
just so you know.
So, I am very close
to hand feeding him, like, so close.
But this magpie is so trusting,
I genuinely think I can hold him.
And that'll be the first time I've ever held
a wild magpie.
Like, I'm gonna freaking go mental.
Hmm, talking about male on stream,
I know my fucking magpie.
The magpie I feed, I can't believe it.
I'm really ahead, do you know the difference
between a male and a female magpie?
I will educate you, little reflin'.
Thank you for your interest in magpies.
So, a male magpie has a white
back of his head,
and a female magpie has
mixed, it can be like a gray,
but males are always
stark white on the back of the head.
Like, you cannot...
Am I fucking lost?
Hello? Is the manager on site?
Where am I...
What am I doing?
Oh.
Oh dear.
Oh dear, oh dear.
Oh dear, oh dear, oh dear.
Eh...
How's Gammy?
I'll need to go visit her.
Um...
So, magpies remember for a very long time.
So, I think as soon as she takes
a bite of a cashew, she'll be like,
oh, I know you, I'll be like, what?
No! A logic puzzle?
Now, hold on, I didn't say not for a logic puzzle.
Ah!
Oh well, there goes the stream.
Like that?
Uh...
No, that can't be.
That's completely wrong.
Look at the bomb piece.
Uh, wrap it up, you're done.
Yeah, I'm...
I feel like that too,
in all honesty.
What the fuck?
How?
Like this?
Type of play supermarket simulator?
Real though?
Cause what the fuck?
Okay, that looks a bit better.
Is it even touching?
Okay, that, right, the red is correct.
That's the good news.
Cause the red goes straight on.
So, at least the red has a fucking hint.
Oh no.
You never frickin warned me this was a logical game?
Can you cheese it?
How do I get up to the yellow?
Whoa, no, you can't cheese that, apparently.
How do I get up to the yellow from the green?
Oh, there's a staircase.
And then the yellow must be a little bit wrong.
Cause, like, the yellow and green are fucked.
What?
No, what?
I need to be able to get the ladder at the top though.
Hello?
What?
No, I, what?
I need to touch, right, I need to be able to grab that ladder.
So it has to be this way.
So what is the green wrong even though I managed to jump on it?
Is that in theory we're doing wrong?
I need it to be, like, near to grab.
Oh!
Hold on, hold on, don't write me out just yet.
Don't write me out.
Hold on, don't put up supermarket simulator yet.
Don't write me out yet.
You look flabbergasted?
That's because I am.
I don't, I don't do logic games.
I don't do logic things.
I can't, I can't see.
If you ask me to visualize something in my head,
you're getting a smudge of a thumbprint, okay?
You're getting a smudge of a thumbprint.
I think...
No way we did that.
100 IQ.
Right, get up the stairs.
Holy moly, holy moly.
Developers saw you were doing...
Whoa!
Oh, it was impenetra-
I wasn't paying attention, I was reading chat.
Right, okay, no, it's fine.
It's fine, sorry.
I never even, like, I heard the sound of fight,
but I was like, oh, that must be for a later thing.
Sorry, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Ow, down, ow, down.
Room temperature IQ, hold on.
And...
All right.
Okay, everyone, close steam.
You don't need to build up supermarket simulator
so you can stream snipe me on it.
Uh...
What?
What's going on here?
What is going on here?
What's going on right?
Let's analyze this.
Let's analyze.
Look at me get eyeballs.
Right, up you go, up you go.
Okay.
I have below freezing IQ.
That's so cute.
40 below.
I love how much you say holy mo-
It's because it's an earworm, it's like,
and you have to do it with a vocal fryer.
It's not real.
It's not real, it's not true.
I might be smarter than a cuttlefish.
Cuttlefish are cephalopods though.
They're super smart.
Like, I know octopus are super smart
or like trying to be like,
uh, maybe let's not be mean to this creature.
It's a bit too high IQ.
And they say like dolphins are really smart as well.
I mean, they say dolphins are smart
and they also are word things,
so I don't know what that means for us.
There's definitely something we can extrapolate
extrapolate from that, can't we?
We fling.
Right, let's enjoy the swinging balls.
Oh!
Just the name Lia.
Dolphins are smart but mean.
Yeah.
Intelligence is evil.
A dolphin girl for Jen too.
Oh!
And that'll be her shtick,
she's just an R-worder.
That's terrible.
That's actually genuinely terrible.
Who said that?
You can't be saying this stuff out loud.
And yet you say it all the time.
I'm in the harbor!
There is no way I'm finishing this game.
No!
But I want to finish it.
I hate playing games and not finishing them.
It kills my soul.
I don't know.
I used to watch like a lot of
like let's play,
like let's game it out type things.
But whenever they don't finish the game,
it freaking does my nips in.
It annoys me so much.
I'm like what's going on?
Where is it?
Where's what I'm looking for?
I don't know.
Does the bother you guys
when like a streamer starts something
but they don't end it?
Like I always try and end it
as best as I can.
Did satisfactory release today?
Oh!
Is it out of early development?
Early access?
Like I like when it's wrapped up
in one stream as well.
Like that's why I don't mind
being an endurance streamer.
Like obviously,
you know you can play games
like Supermarket Simulator or TCG.
That doesn't count, okay?
I'm too used to streamers
never finishing the game.
As long as someone says the B word,
that is not only one true time
that I have never done it.
You know what I'm saying?
Never.
I mean Pikmin doesn't count either.
Wait, satisfactory 1.0 is out?
Did it?
Congratulations!
It's one of the rare steam games
that go from early access
and actually be finished.
The B word?
There's this video game called
Blinks, okay?
And it's a child's game.
And yet they ask for frame
perfect move sets, okay?
Frame perfect?
I don't know who they think they are.
Still waiting on Killer Bean forever.
Oh is that game?
I don't know that.
I can hear birds chirping.
We're in the Garden of Eden.
Like the hit video game.
Whoa, why can you not?
Can you walk to the end of the pole?
Oh!
I didn't realize I wasn't supposed to jump there.
Hold on a minute.
The crane, the crane, okay.
Save, go from highest checkpoint.
Puts me over here.
Killer Bean?
Almost speedrun strat.
Pokemon go to the poles.
Wait, what does that mean?
Higher than the checkpoint.
Checkpoint is really true.
Can we get much higher?
So high.
Have you ever not heard about Killer Bean?
Killer Bean Watch Along?
It's an anime?
Yes, they're making me confuzzled here.
Right, if I stay on the-
You stink.
Heaven.
You having a lot to say?
Hmm, whatever.
It's a movie.
Oh, Stony or Sweet Summer Train.
Wait, whoa, what's going on?
Sorry, just checking.
These girls and me sent me a message.
Right, is this supposed to be the Heaven checkpoint then?
The music that's just looming in the dark is like-
in the background is like so now.
He's a bean and he has guns and is a mercenary.
You know what?
Right, take me there, load it.
You've not unlocked it.
Are we in the city then?
Right, we're in the city.
Okay.
Also me, are these games so satisfying me?
Where are we?
I have to take a crane that takes an extra 20 seconds.
Unplayable, truly unplayable.
Okay, right, and I'm around there.
It's like taking me along with it, you know what I mean?
Whoa.
Okay, now take me on the hay bales.
They're bouncy.
They lied, I thought there were going to be platforms that spin.
They're telling Fibonacci sequences to me.
I can't believe it.
Was it one, three, five, sevens?
Was it?
It can only be divided by itself, until a whole number.
What plan?
Immediately, immediately.
Isn't that just primes?
Fibonacci, like the hit, from the hit video game Vulture?
Yeah!
I don't play more ballet, truly.
I can't claim on them.
I can just stay on it then.
Can I know if it's like a track?
I was like, I know the band.
Bouncy, bouncy, bouncy.
I'm going to read the word, Bouncy.
No.
No, that's wrong.
One plus one is two.
Two plus one is three.
Three and two is five.
Five and three is eight.
Eight and five is 13.
Yeah, that sounds better.
Okay, and then are we going to miss the slate?
I think, oh well.
Might not miss it.
Might be able to...
Okay, we've got it.
As you can tell,
Mass wasn't my strong suit at school.
You know, honestly, you think I've probably been
really confident?
I always see folk that say that.
Oh, you have so much confidence as a streamer in that.
And I was like, how are you in real life?
And I was like, I can't even look folk in the eyes.
What made you so confident?
And it's like, you know, the comfort of my room.
My room made me confident.
I'm so comfy.
Everything's nice.
Everything's cozy.
What's nine plus ten?
21?
You stupid.
You know what I'm saying?
I can count this many.
Ten.
Did I reach that?
Oh, I can.
Oh, Jesus.
If you're looking for a solo team,
I wonder who the dev team is
if they have anything more.
I know this game is supposed to be
made with multiplayer in mind,
but genuinely satisfying.
I'm enjoying myself.
I'm having a good time.
I can't imagine completing this,
though, as a four-man team.
This looks like it would take literal days
for four people to sync up perfectly.
Yeah, that's kind of
genuinely and wholeheartedly insane.
We jump stream.
I don't even think I'm 50% of the way through the game.
And I've been at the height of 1,800 meters,
so I don't know what the height of the end of the game is.
Maybe 10,000 meters?
Does anyone know?
You're having a good time, good time.
Don't stop me now.
I'm having such a good time.
I'm having a ball.
I don't want to stop at all.
Mommy, that's not how math works.
Wait, what are those things?
Wait, what did I say?
Me and my cousin played the game.
We finished the game in 10 hours.
Bro, are you still cousins after that?
In the nicest way, have you disowned each other yet?
Oh, is that how you can get around Wincest?
Just disown each other, do it,
and then rename yourselves
once you've finished having your fun?
I feel like that's a really good legal...
What on earth am I supposed to do here?
I'm supposed to avoid the rocks.
Okay, I mean...
Shit.
You're not making it easy for me.
Uh...
Okay.
Am I skinny enough?
Okay, I'm skinny enough.
I'm on the OZM pick.
Then are you worried?
Disowning someone is not a legal thing, mommy.
Oh, do you not have to go to court
and be like, we're not related anymore?
Like, you legally change my surname
because I don't want to be a part of this family?
It's a hack.
Okay, this is getting a bit scary up here, though.
Oh.
Oh my god, the game's so kind.
They stop spawning it the closer you get.
No, please don't you ever listen to me.
With this one weird trick,
normies hate it.
You can get around to consenting adults.
Shocking.
Honestly, don't listen to me, though.
I'm completely lost.
I admit it.
You already know my viewpoints on it.
I admit what others are too afraid to say.
What do I do?
Oh!
What?
Okay, hold on.
Someone called into Texas.
She's lost the plot.
I'll come...
Hold on.
You know what?
Right, right, right, right, right.
I'll wait one second and then go.
Okay, there we go.
I need to aim it.
That looks right.
No, it doesn't.
Keep shocking behavior.
Keep going.
I'm allowed to say it.
Apparently it gets you in trouble and stuff.
And I'm just like...
I'm shocked.
Shocked, I say.
I know, I can't believe it.
The mastermind behind Amy's creation.
Yes, I'm going to court to change my last name to Beezus.
Stop!
That would be so cute.
Don't actually do it, though.
I think your family would legit disown you.
Thank you.
I'd find it cute, anyway.
I'd find it cute.
I'm already 120th done in the game.
Are you serious?
There's that much to this game?
I mean, I believe you.
Is this not where I'm supposed to go?
Am I supposed to jump off that pier, then?
Almost 200,000 p...
2,000 pings?
Wait, I can't figure out how to get...
progress in.
I'll go climb this...yup.
That's where I came from.
Cotton-eyed Joe?
Because where did I come from?
And where did I go?
No, you...what?
Am I not supposed to go there?
How did I get on that platform in particular?
Enosys.
Are you winning?
A wee bit, kind of.
I'm a bit unsure what...
how I get onto that edge, but...
I'm good at edge normally, so I think we'll be okay.
So I think we'll be okay.
Oh, you've finally got to the bottom
of why I say enolines.
Because after we have
conducted our enosys...
Why can I not climb?
It's really like a secret.
I can climb onto that.
I can't climb onto that.
And it looks like I need to climb onto this.
But it's not letting me.
I can't believe it.
The only reason I can't progress is because I'm too daft.
That cannae be right.
It must be something with the top of the boat.
Because...what the fuck is this?
Nope.
Right, hold on.
Right, hold on, hold on.
I'm just spamming this space bar.
Is it like a ledge thing?
Uh, anyone played this game before?
Does anyone know the answer?
Uh...
Don't think I won't open up marshmallows
in yet for half an hour, because I'll do it.
Hold on.
Don't let me cook! That's the problem!
When you let me cook, I get in trouble.
Come on.
What? What's not clicking?
Something isn't...
This?
You've...
You've frickin' fricks!
When will you learn?
When will you learn your actions upset me?
Right, okay.
I'm sorry, I don't know...
This?
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That was very anticlimactic.
Very, very anticlimactic.
Dude.
Prepare to suffer and regret ever wanting to leave?
Why would...
Why would we be suffering?
Every day I'm suffering.
Where are we?
A chopper.
Okay, next...
Next location.
Take me, Mr. Chopper!
Uh, yeah, there...
I have no idea how long the base game takes, but...
That's rough.
Get to the chopper.
Uh, I see platforms.
Apparently we are at the floating, levitating rocks of Pandora now.
Yes, I like Avatar.
Both can.
But I've only seen Avatar, the last airbender.
I've not seen the Legend of Korra.
Okay, we're at the temple now.
I don't know how far in the temple is, but we're at the temple.
What if you just jump back down?
I'll do it at the end.
I'll see what, uh...
Predator, what's long when?
Like, Alien vs. Predator?
I've only seen Alien 1 and then that Alien...
Other 1.
Prometheus, I saw Prometheus.
I actually really enjoyed Prometheus.
I think there's a new Alien movie that came out.
I assume I claimed the vines?
Yeah.
Gotta get the Unobtainable.
Oh.
Wait, well there's something over here as well.
A random platform if I were to...
fall down, I guess.
Lika Drug Fiend?
Thank you, the beauty lord, for the tip.
I mean, hopefully I have enough content to make you laugh.
Someone sent me another thingy.
And it was like, oh, uh...
Easy, easy, steady, steady.
Clean that stem, clean that stem.
Alien Romulus of Water Shrooms, awesome.
Yeah, I've not seen it yet.
Overdose on Strony?
How would you get too many tingles?
I guess I can get up here?
Yeah.
Ooh, a bubble.
Would be a shame if I popped it.
Huh?
Wait, whoa!
Why is it moving?
Oh, it's making the platforms appear.
Okay.
It's making the platforms appear.
Uh, just gotta keep it in with a bubble.
Okay, it's going a bit further ahead.
Not to panic anyone, but it's going a bit ahead.
Don't panic!
Stop panicking!
I'm coming!
Oh my god, I think I just saw the back of it there.
Okay, don't panic.
Don't panic.
You're panicking, I don't know where you're panicking.
I'm panicking.
Oh, someone's screaming in the background.
Okay.
Don't panic.
Oding on Strony is when you ink four times in a row!
Honestly!
Thank you, Mr. Bubble,
for your service.
We're really thankful.
Please don't ever do that again.
That's scary.
We're like, we are in Pandora.
Hello, it's there.
Ooh, there's like
visual stuff
to look at.
Mmm.
Oh, it's Aztec!
Wow, what do we feel about Aztec
Reflings?
What do we feel about Aztec
inspirations on things?
Hmm.
What do we feel
about Aztec
an inspired
to bring eternal reason?
Oh, that's so cute!
I got like a little game I get to play.
It's cool.
Oh, you like Aztec things?
Okay.
Just checking.
Just wondering, you know.
Just thinking.
Thinking out loud.
La la la la la la la la la la la.
Hmm.
How did that even work out?
I don't know.
I'll take the wings though.
Sacrificing each other?
No, actually not
sacrifice at all.
A rather unique
unique
cool gamer moves, literally.
Opening something.
Oh, this door. Okay.
This is cool.
I like this.
Are you squidding me right now?
Oh, Brian!
No, Brian!
Brian.
Brian needs coffee apparently.
This is the first day.
He's like really struggled.
Hmm.
Brian, my love.
The forbidden love.
That was like five minutes later,
literally.
Imagine...
Imagine a Latino region.
Yeah, wouldn't that be fucking awesome?
Wouldn't that be crazy?
Wouldn't that be...
Wait, what?!
Stop with the IQ puzzles.
Right now.
What?!
I'm looking.
Um...
My eyes are open.
Cash grab time is over.
Yeah, clearly.
They were not kidding when they were like,
yeah, we're gonna make this hard.
How is...
Anyone supposed to complete this game?
Yeah, wouldn't be crazy if a Latina
or a Spanish kind of
applied.
Wouldn't that be nice?
Wouldn't that be...
That would be nice, wouldn't it?
What the fuck am I...
I don't get it.
So what?
I jump on the platform and then what?
Are these ropes real?
No, they're not. What?!
The ropes aren't real.
So then...
I literally...
That?!
Oh, the ropes aren't real.
I thought I had to, like,
a combination with the ropes figure a way out.
Up.
Yeah, sorry.
Sorry.
Things do take me a few extra moments
that you might get instantly.
My apologies, good refling.
Thank you for your patience.
I love listening to...
Yes, imagine...
Imagine, I'd just say...
Action.
Hold on.
Hold on, you slut.
We're trying to learn a bit of something else.
Cmo ests?
Puta madre.
Mmm.
All right.
Well, Strani, you can't just pick people
purely based on their voice.
Yes, I can, and I will.
What are you going to do about it?
I want a sexy little Latina.
I want a little slutty.
Uh...
Shiny.
Wait, what?
Strani, you can't do that.
Well, I'm not the only one on the hiring team, so...
Well...
Don't make me fall for more accents.
Mmm.
Accents are on the desirable.
Accents are very, very desirable.
Eh.
At this point in time,
this one's going to say hola.
Could you imagine that?
Hola. Cmo ests?
Cmo ests?
I don't know what her voice would sound like.
Puta madre?
No, do a Spanish accent.
Hola.
Cmo ests?
Oh, mi hoy, mi hoy.
I don't know any Spanish.
I'm so sorry.
Give me a Spanish sentence,
and I'll pretend to be Spanish.
I'm such a loser.
Mommy's too Scottish to pull off, honestly.
The Asian Shrine.
As opposed to...
The Scottish Shrine?
Was that doodable?
Mi hoy, mi hoy. It might have been.
I don't know, I see that meme everywhere, but I've never played it.
Te amo.
Te amo mucho.
Riefling.
Yeah, I cannot do a Spanish accent.
I can't think of any Spanish content
of consumed either
to mimic someone's accent.
As a Spanish guy,
put a madre.
To say coqueo,
you also go cocana.
To say...
my name is, you say soy.
So I'd be like soy strone.
Tienes que ir a la biblioteca?
Oh, dnde est la biblioteca?
Yeah, that's what I need.
I need a bright little fucking
espanol, or a bright little latina.
That'd be great.
Or a tomboy. I'll take a tomboy.
Or...
I think there's something programmed in terms
to be attracted to foreign accents.
I think because it's different, it's new
and unique.
I cannot overstate how boring
my voice is to literally any other
Scott, but...
Where the fuck
am I going? I'm genuinely lost in Chinatown
right now.
Where's my boss lady?
I want my noodles.
Where's my auntie?
I can't find my auntie, I'm lost.
Your pronunciations are really good.
I do love taking
a good shot in the dark.
Oh yeah, to say soy
is like gracias.
Oh no, that's thank you, dumbass.
Gracias.
Can I go up here?
Bruh, I'm lost in Chinatown
the fuck.
Oh, right.
Okay, well, the platform
things are probably a hint to where to get started.
So what, up here?
Oh, oh, just look up.
Okay, five head.
Sorry equals perdn.
Perdn.
Perdn. How do you say mister?
Perdn, seor.
Oh, yabliet.
Are you? Wait, if I go reload
last checkpoint, it's totally not
going to put me there. It's going to put me...
Only up stonks.
You can say perdn or lo siento.
Lo siento.
Oh, Johnny.
La janta es moluca.
Perdn.
Lo siento.
Oh, seor.
Seor, gimme ya.
How do you say winches?
I don't know how you say a winner in Spanish.
I know
it's ochinchin
in Japanese.
Spanish.
What? Actually, you know what?
You actually can wait.
Right, it better put me higher.
Alright, thank you.
A penne.
Penne.
Sa chicha.
Oh, you know what?
Tackle
in Spanish is tackle.
Thank you.
You know, right, what's going on here?
Why can't that brain not process
it?
Is it moving?
Is that what it is?
I think it's moving.
It has to be.
Is that moving forward and backwards?
Or am I just really bad at this game?
I'm just really slow.
Okay, right, let's do it.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, right. Okay, we did it.
We got past it and we've defeated the evil.
You just keep stopping perfectly
for it to whack you off.
Chinese food in China
is just cold food. Right.
Enough.
Reflins.
If Penne to his penne,
what is
chupanopika?
He just craves the spank, honestly.
Right, let's get right
into the claim.
Right, I will
wrap up the next time I fall off.
I will read some marshmallows
and then I'll redirect into Shibi.
What's Shibi doing today, Reflins?
You must tell me. You must tell me at once.
I'm redirecting into Shibi
in 20 minutes.
Italian.
Tackle to backwards is
Oh, she playing the monkey game.
Monkey.
Monkey. Monkey.
Remember that time they
remastered Super Monkey Ball Deluxe
and I played the OG version like a dumbass?
Because I didn't know better?
Mm-hmm.
That's right. I didn't know any better.
I didn't know
any better.
Monkey.
Who goes there?
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Accidental SPH stream.
Wait, what did I say?
I already forgot. Oh, it bounces.
Thanks for the stream.
Fuck it, steady on. I'm no ended yet.
Shibi's not even up yet.
Fuck it now.
Getting ding-dong ditched already.
I can't believe it.
The original monkey before Goku?
Is Goku a monkey?
No.
It's not Goku. It's like that Laffy
one is a monkey.
I'm like 99% sure Laffy's a monkey.
I think he's from one piece.
Oh, who goes there?
Uh...
He meant your Super Monkey Ball stream.
Oh, when I said that, yeah.
To be fair,
I don't know how that didn't let me go in.
I saw it.
But what am I supposed to do with that one inch?
Like...
I was right. I'm right. You're wrong.
There's nothing you can do about it.
Goku is a Saiyan
which is a race of space monkey people.
What the fuck?
What is going on in that anime?
I'm like, as long as you guys are happy,
what is going on in that anime?
Huh.
Hey! Wait.
Hold on. Mommy's missing something.
Oh, it's this.
I don't have time to claim on it.
No, no, no, no. Come back. I'm sorry.
No, baby. Come back.
No! I'll make it up to you.
Fuck.
Did you just call him Laffy?
A monkey anime guy named Laffy?
Saiyan?
I want to hear you pronounce Laffy's name again.
Oh, Laffy!
Is it with a U? Laffy?
Isn't this a little chain together
just basically only up?
Wait, is there a game called only up?
Laffy?
Oh my god. Wait, I can't get on board.
Okay, I can get on board now.
One, two,
three, one,
two, three,
one, two,
fuck this. I'm off.
Stash Power.
Son Goku is based off of Song Wukong.
Both have
an flying cloud.
Both have a magical staff that extends near
infinity. Both achieve godlike power.
Okay. Thank you, Stash Power for the tip.
I'm learning.
Laffy is
Laffy like Guffey.
Laffy, Guffey.
Laffy.
Only up was the one that got removed
from her stone assets.
Oh.
It's pronounced
Luffy.
Right, so controversial take.
Why is it no spell
Luffy?
Have you ever thought about that?
Why it's no spell like that?
My name's
Stroney.
Okay, Stroney.
Right?
Ken, how there's no random
letters that are not even a part of
my name in it? Aye.
What is going on? It's because he's Brazilian.
Oh my god, come to Brazil.
Cousin Japan, there's no Lu.
It's Lu. Oh, it's La?
Oh, right. Okay, hold on.
I'll take it back. I'll take it back.
Sorry, forgive my ignorance.
Saronzo.
Because it's written.
Okay, should we call you
Saronny? No.
Do not call me Ministerone Soup.
I've had enough. Whoa.
Okay.
Monkey. Monkey.
Monkey.
Hmm.
Oh, this one's cute. What the heck?
I like this.
I have been awarded a platform.
Oh, no.
It tilts.
Ministerone.
I'm just out here mining.
I'm a cover in the Minecraft
shippost song.
Oh, it was a shippost.
But yeah, I wanted to
see if AC would be done for doing.
Why is this dealer?
Taking the piece I've been
standing here
for 13 minutes.
Like, I'd love it in a wee accent.
I don't want to be so cute,
but I don't want to give AC any more work.
I have to wait until
the girls come to me.
No, I can't laugh yet.
This is so cute.
Right. I promise I'm going to wrap up.
Wait a minute.
The game's a thick tunnel.
I'll see you that much.
Okay.
What is this dealer?
Oh, my God.
It's Legolord of the Rings.
Oh, right. Okay.
Well, speaking of Legolord of the Rings,
I'm going to open up Marshmallows
very quickly.
Shawnee, have you ever seen Death Note?
I saw this, like, the first few episodes,
but I never finished it.
But I do want to actually finish it.
But I don't know how long it is either.
Brian.
Darlan.
Wait.
You're going to be talking to me when the
I'm having the time.
For my donation.
For my tip that's been like, 30 minutes ago.
I'll let you know.
Hey, Shawnee, I want to tell you
an embarrassing Legol story.
What? You shoved one up your ass.
Hi, Shawnee, I want to tell you an
embarrassing Legol story that happened to
me when I was a kid. There's not...
There's a not Lego company that used to
make Halo kits to build.
I was probably 12, 13 years old
However, there was a production issue or something and there were a few pieces that didn't fit together no matter how hard I tried.
It got to the point where I started crying out frustration. My mom walked in and was wondering why I was crying and explained that I couldn't build it.
We took it back to the store to return it. My mom told the lady at the return counter that I cried because I couldn't put it together and I was really embarrassed.
Oh no, that's an out of context story though. That's not nice.
If it makes you feel better, I cried at Kung Fu Chaos and my dad never comforted me.
So I was playing Kung Fu Chaos and I got 5 stars in the director's last mission.
Now this is as a child obviously. I was like 3 years old or something playing this.
I thought I got 5 stars but he took it away the last second.
So I burst out crying and I went to my dad to comfort me.
But not to be stereotypical but he just didn't know how to comfort me.
All he had to do was pat me on the back and be like, there there strongy, you'll get him next time.
But he didn't know what to say and I just remember thinking like, oh I'm not going back to my dad for emotional support again. What was that?
And obviously I just never cried at a video game since then.
But it was really good. Is your dad also just like, oh wait until I tell you about World War 2 and World War 1 planes.
You want to know why I know so much about World War 1 and 2 planes?
Hi Stormy, hi Wiefling. I have nothing waiting to say, I just want to let you know I love you.
Please sit on my face. I love you too, yes I was sitting here.
An attempt was made, much as many such cases.
That hit someone considering my dad. Yeah, there's a reason
he was really happy. I play like Crimson Skies and Mech Stuff.
The Spitfire I believe is his favorite plane. Mine personally is the SR-71, the Blackbird, it's my favorite.
Need autistic children with strongy.
Aww, you want to give me pregnant? You want to give me a baby?
I'm obviously a thing. I'm waiting.
Crimson Skies. Yes, I played Crimson Skies because of my dad.
Bias is a strona ski, the Imposka. Is that real?
It's me. Is that real? Wait, what part? The Crimson Skies where I played that game or the ovulation pun?
Blackbird is your favorite too? Yeah, yeah, the SR-71.
The most interesting plane I have learned about. There may be other planes out there that I haven't learned about, but yeah.
Forcing your daughter to listen to your hyper fixation.
It was just like how it got passed then. Like my dad played video games, I watched him play video games,
I then played video games. It's just kind of like a simulation. You do what's around you
and my dad watches. That's what I was saying. When my dad was here, I don't know who's playing. Is it War?
Not Warhammer. That War Thunder game, someone made a video and it was like,
what if we dropped an atomic bomb and a thing and he was sitting watching it and I was just like, yep, that's my dad.
He's just happy watching plane. Yeah, yeah, War Thunder. He was watching people
record videos and all that. You play it? Well, if you upload videos, my dad probably watches you.
Because he says he's too old to play games these days, which he's not. I'm gonna try and get him to
play PC build simulator because I think he'd really enjoy it. He likes building his own PCs.
Like he built my PC back in Scotland and all of that. My sister gave a TV remote without batteries
and said, that press and the buttons helped her. Aw, you got got. I have a friend who has
6,000 hours in that game. Yeah, my dad feels the same way. I could totally,
I could totally chill watching that stuff with him. Literally, fucking bit of video game stuff but
anything nerdy and all that and you're good to go with my dad. You don't have to be,
oh what happens if we don't, you know, Stormy's dad wouldn't accept me because they didn't. No,
my dad's a nerd. I'm a nerd. We're all nerds. Life's good. Okay, life is good.
A bit of cellic on the side, that's all. A bit of cellic, a bit of green. Green's our color,
all right? Green is the color of the Cuddles family. So if you like green,
so a tank feature bar, you want fucking panzer and gentoo? No.
I wanted to play World of Warcraft on my pops and miss the pandora but he quit because he felt
too slow. Yeah, my dad says that to me. He's like, I'm too slow for video games and I want to shake
him and be like, no dad, don't say that. I hate when my dad acknowledges he's getting older,
it freaks me the fuck out. I'm just like, I can't handle it. I could, I cannot handle it.
I cannot handle it. I hate when he acknowledges he's getting older. It freaks me out.
It freaks me out. I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. Right, customization. Redirect into
she be cut and bum, but she's not up yet, but that is okay. I'm going to do.
I wonder if we should do a deadlock stream together actually for the next stream game.
Is deadlock in beta? Is it finished? Is it out? What's, what's the story of deadlock at this point
in time? Because I actually don't know what the story of deadlock is right now. Make a
Vtuber model for your dad, real. Ask your dad about Avril Vulcan sometime.
A stunning dad club win. Unfortunately, he would dox me like within a heartbeat.
No, as much as I would love like a mech type character, it's impossible. It's not possible,
how you say it's not possible. Right, okay, I have sheepster stream. Is it going to work?
Is it worth it? Let me work it. I remember watching my dad play Star Wars Force Unleash.
Oh my God. Yeah, I'm playing Star Wars Force Unleash because of that. My dad played that game
too. We're going to be playing it in October, I think. Most of the dad, my dad was the fucking
T-Rex Vtuber I said no to. Wait until I show you that design. I'll see what happens. As I said,
the concept artist wants to try and submit that girl again to me, but I'm just like a dinny and
move Ivan with it. But well, now that we have two new team members, I can maybe show them that design.
I'm just like, it's fucking ugly. I just don't like it. But I don't know if it's a male versus female
girls. Okay, it might be. It genuinely might be a male versus female girls.
Definitely redirecting and to become one with the monkey stream.
T-Rex woman. Yes, I am. I will leak it. Mommy, do you like Wendy's?
You'd like Wendy's tentacles or lane on your face? Oh, fuck you, Riflin. Wait, what? I thought you
meant the franchise in America. Riflin, you got me. Boo. Very fine. You get a round of applause for
getting me. There you go. Yeah, laugh it up. You got me. I thought you were talking about the franchise.
My dad's flavor of autism is trains. When I was a kid, he would take me to the train tracks and
watch the train. Oh, that's the name. You'll have nice memories about watching the train.
You need to be invited to access Deadlock. Next time you add me for a stream snip game,
you can invite me into it. What?
What? It's not just an open beta?
It's like a one-on-one invite. Like, one person has it and then they can send it to them and then what?
It's fun to toss a stormtrooper. I always max out on lightning as fast as possible.
Are Emmy's marshmallows still? As far as I'm aware, yeah. I don't think marshmallow,
nothing like that has been affected. When you have it, you can send it to all your friends.
How bizarre. It's an alpha, but if someone gets in, they can invite as many people as they want.
Who? Just open the fucking servers at that point. Oh, if you're in the alpha, you can
invite as many people as you want. Just open the servers. Jeez. Unlimited power. I like lightning.
Nah, just a marketing strategy, which is help. I can't believe it. Valve are doing the tried and
tried and true and tested methods and it's working yet again. Valve is up.
Astroni, have you ever heard of the recent VTuber? No, I'm not saying that name.
I think, uh, I think Mercy is one of Mercy's first concept and name, who's Candace for a laugh.
Now that you've just reminded me. Speaking of ovulation, do you plan on uploading the picture
this day, despite the current happenings with little sis? Yeah, it's already been
like in quotation marks, the Emmy situation has already been dealt with. If that makes sense,
whatever the result is in 48 hours time will be the result. Okay. So either she starts fresh
or we get their account back. That's how it is. Just to reassure the pinpals again,
when your account gets done for factual thingies, you are not perma-ban. You can make an account
right away. You can start up again the next day if you so desired. So either the account comes back
or it doesn't and Emmy starts fresh. As far as I'm aware, as far as I can see and like as I said,
like I knew this is a very high possibility. So we're waiting on YouTube's decision on
to see what the result is. So don't worry, she's coming back. There's no perma-bans. That's not
really a thing. Well, it's perma-ban if you do like hatred stuff like that. We don't do that.
Yeah, but the 50k, yes. Obviously, if Emmy were to start fresh, I think all the girls will agree
with me when I say this, that we will put advertisements on her channel and that nature
of things. Emmy got banned when? You didn't hear the news, you Goober? Her account's gone. Her
YouTube account. I got banned a couple of hours ago, I think. I wasn't, I've not been awake.
I woke up like 30-ish minutes before stream. But please don't worry, it's not perma-ban.
So you're just gonna have to support your little sister extra hard, clear?
Yeah. But yeah, please don't worry. I have been fully aware that this is, it's not deleted, no.
So the appeal's been sent off. We just have to wait. And either they'll say, yes, you can have
your account back or no, you can't. And if the answer is no, then it's very likely she just
starts fresh and that's it. If she wants to do a funny little mock debut, then sure,
more than happy. Not sure what to do about the old content, no? I hope there's been
Archive and on, possibly. Or would she just want to start completely fresh? I'm not sure.
That's probably what I don't have answers to. Anyway, right, I'm gonna redirect
into Sheepsters, thank you so so much. I do apologise for not having my ever-ending
lurking streams or doing X, Y, Z, L, M, N, O, P. I do need to do quite a lot back around things.
So I'm going to end stream. I'm gonna make a cup of tea. If you're a member,
then I will be watching Austin Powers for the first time. And if you're not a member,
I will see you tomorrow, as always. And I'm gonna redirect you into my lovely genmate,
Shebecott and Bumble. Please don't, please don't worry. Everything is okay. I assure you.
I did think that far ahead. I know it's surprising that I thought that far ahead,
but please don't worry, okay? Everything's gonna be okay in the end. You know us.
But yes, thank you so so much for the shorter stream. I do apologise for not wrapping it up.
I didn't realise how big this game was, to be honest. I thought it was like an old thing at the end.
But I will see you cute. It'd be too east tomorrow for stream sniping with Shebe
on Left 4 Dead. I get to play Left 4 Dead for the first time tomorrow,
which I'm excited about. So don't be shy to add me on. I'll show it on stream,
but don't add me now, but I mean, you already know what to add. Right,
I'll see you goofy goobers tomorrow. Please enjoy, Shebe. Oh, I'll give you a kiss for,
well, I was gonna say for every metre I've climbed, but yeah, no. Not for 2,600 kisses.
That's a special stream that comes later, okay? Alright, love ya.
See you tomorrow and enjoy Shebe and enjoy me and Shebe tomorrow if you can make it.
You had 26 kisses. Okay.
There we go.
Ta-da.
Enjoy Shebe. See you tomorrow, goofy goobah, or see you in five minutes with Austin Powers.